yeah welcome to this video playing
monkey Bishop from Spain okay let's see
um yeah played many nums oohs yeah but
it's a well it's um it's an interesting
opening leading to double edged plain
and very often I I went for the sameish
but usually I do that while the e3 move
order b6 now can also play 92 okay so
he's playing one of the absolute main
lines of the b6 variation and as usual I
have forgotten what I'm playing here wow
I had this on the board last year and
I'm in a tournament game
I think t5 md5 b5 g3 is something like
that I was a g3 g3 instantly hmmm I have
completely forgotten what what I'm
playing here g3 I cannot play he cannot
play d5 on that because I'd before using
this stranger of peace position I
actually think I'm playing this move
Bishop d7 d 585 Bishop g2 on IDM takes
and then Bishop g2 black normally place
with b-52 get to get some concrete play
in the center I think b5 here
of course the problem for white is that
he's played in a very let's say yeah
it's a quite a sophisticated to set up
yet nighty too and it's very slow it's
not a very natural set up with flu and
peace development and play two lots of
pawn moves III g3a3 and so on and blacks
got all pieces out and I still have two
bishops at home so the of course the
good thing for widest the night on a six
is bad the bishop got a five is some
slightly questionable as well it's
active but it's not clear that this is a
good piece in the long run and of course
if I manage to just capture on d5 and
have a benoni kind of structure then the
build the pieces on a five and a six are
just ridiculous uh-huh interestingly i
really have no idea about the theory
here um okay but i can just castle right
it's still
yeah I can castle he cannot really takes
e4 as deep as he was hanging yeah loops
loops good normal and good maybe seat XD
five also was okay I mean it certainly
was ok but maybe it was better I don't
know don't want to spend lots of time
early here and yeah this is actually an
interesting question if I want to maybe
take with the pawn and try to yeah I try
to say that this Bishop is just a bad
piece I like this idea after night takes
he probably just takes he ll c 3 and now
my idea is to take on d5 with the pond
and then ideally place see for should be
too then it would be great bishop on
between would have a great diagonal take
with the porn C for Bishop b2 and the a5
bishop is just pointing into thin air
the other idea actually it's night f4
and then take with a piece but this is
really good I think good idea I can play
pawn to c4 gap and he plays it
immediately good news yeah I forgot
about that forgot about that that
possibility I mean you you you recognize
I saw it but just had just delayed okay
it's not done it's not fatal or anything
but I really didn't didn't appreciate
this
hmm ok I'd like to have the bishop on d4
if you place rook e8
night c5 this problem night c5 now okay
but okay i'm running a temple this is
very important after 95 Bishop e3 I'm
actually threatening like Bishop takes
d5 winning this piece so it doesn't have
the time to play 95 Andrew p8 quickly
attacking the epon okay i also have
queen see to it would be great to have
the bishop on d4 Bishop e3 to deform the
bishop would would be fantastic on
deform it covers c3 and points towards
the Kings side this position is really
am aiming form for a king side attack at
the end because he's got the stranded
piece on a five and the bed bishop on b7
which just does nothing so it's at the
end I'd whip it will be a king cytotec
with bishop on d4 and trying to put
piece pressure on on the Kings side look
yeah okay let's check this quickly if i
put bishop the bush appear immediately
maybe he's got night b3
now maybe if I have a more precise a
more precise way to to play
hmm not easy at all what is what what
would be helpful here what I'd like to
do is actually exchanged notes if I got
the nights off and the bishop on d4 it's
a it simply broke very brilliant but the
night to d3 or be threesome is quite a
problem maybe maybe maybe a
strengthening moves like Quincy to this
covers in form so in case of rookie edge
is not gaining time and it covered to
this point so that actually 94 is some
an additional idea
hmm 91 and 55 so every strange they're
probably not
mmm
then I d4 is not bad at all night f5
it's not too consistent with the bishop
t4 is but night f5s ER also night f5
Bishop deform would be would be
brilliant of course
they're five squares is problematic hmm
between a four really maybe okay but if
I if I attack e seven ninety six I doubt
that he is able to play Queen a form
maybe it's not maybe not objectively
great but Queen a form I know I can play
97 win the exchange but he's got
attacking attacks on C 3 a 3 and so on
yeah still that should work it really
shouldn't okay my idea Bishop d for
Bishop age three possible so Bishop d
foil
just attacking g7 and Bishop aged three
years that's an additional additional
problem okay
Bishop atrium hmm that cannot be bad
ringing
it can be bad it can be bad it's not no
no such thing that no such thing as an
oven unknown debatable rule in chess it
can be bad but it looks very dangerous
the night discoveries maybe King a jade
is probably a good move anyway and then
it's not it's not a check if I'm that
moves the night
okay so he's still attacking you form i
need to get the Queen Oh gun tweenty one
somewhere to g4 without the Queen no
maid okay let's first cavity for every
place 93 I'm just ignoring this giving
up the exchange this really am this is
not 22 where is some okay maybe I can
take I don't mind that too much or
should I actually move the bishop it's
on f4 it's a good square for this piece
as well
yeah provoking f6 of course also has
opened some possibilities for a piece
coming to e6 envision Bishop c8
preparing
yep good wolf good defensive move oh
come on
yeah Bishop c8 how do i reply
it's not so clear-cut actually
yeah yeah he's defending this quite well
while I'm playing badly probably both
hmm I'm not sure at all if I how to how
to proceed him i was expecting much more
that you would take with the Queen
ok I wanted to play a for first ok but
for good about that
okay but isn't this at the end a week on
b5
I really I really must have played this
this very battling the middle game was
was excellent for white really I was
really thinking I'm close to winning
okay i know i'm an optimist and chest
but still it looked them it looked
really great hmm ok how to proceed here
I want to make sure that she doesn't
play in five rugby one and King up to d4
then maybe try to do something against
the Queen side now look be one first
probably better okay I need to speed up
also big
I didn't like that too much so f 4 yeah
this is good anyway or lease them fine
so King King to defile or F for now I
need to play a for really that some some
stage cannot yeah come on
it's three against two after all
yeah it's a good end game wyd certainly
is somewhat better because of the pawn
structure the single pound on a three is
basically stopping both be pawns so if
in effect i'm playing four against three
here d 5 e 4 and so on oh I cannot allow
rock age 7 so this is check this
shouldn't be possible okay look here and
no threatening f5
um a three
yeah but I'm winning winning winning a
house here oh look f seven one two three
one two yeah better him check check no
just here then taking both be pawns or
just March with the own three parts Ian
Black resigned yeah but I really don't
understand the middle game I must have
played I must have played some strange
rules it really felt like like is almost
out played here but he played very good
defense of mercy for and someone this
was all very very nice so yeah I'm not
sure about this one maybe maybe 94 is
not really consistent the computer is
quite modest here with 0.34 white Bishop
f4 here yeah of course of course how
does it offend d6
now k can play this one may be here this
is actually quite quite um complicated
Bishop every baby okay about this and it
shouldn't be bad I mean they have I
played this one that the comp wants to
go here and maybe this isn't hacked the
way to go cannot do that this is a
really really big big fork so and this
one is this one coming and d7 terrible
he needs to go here and then 94 yeah
this is good this is good night landing
only six with whatever peace yeah this
is strong this is really strong good
computer move I didn't consider to take
the night at all but i was also i was i
was just thinking okay this is going to
play that one and then i'm going to
secular exchange like this for example
let's say here and this is is a strong
attack I mean maybe rope the eight
bishops eh still defense this and I
underestimated this idea even in the
game edster it's still uncomfortable for
white i'm not i'm not in any trouble but
i really thought i would be much better
and it's not simply not the case yeah I
I would this was inaccurate I thought I
need to play f three and a four and i
just put put every first but a force of
course better just no good covering here
said he cannot play be fibers just
better
and here he took this chance here it's a
question if he should really play Bishop
b6 I don't think you should why not just
here and maybe prepare this without
having them the pawn structure destroyed
this is probably not fatal but it gives
white something i'm pretty sure and now
okay maybe I need to play more precisely
here not sure yeah raji for stopping a
fight but he can play look at eight yeah
exactly and no this one this wasn't
exactly great yep maybe it is still good
what can you do he's always tied to the
pawn I'm going to play King up here and
and this one still it looks strange to
play yeah but whoop you want I need to
player maybe this was good after all I
need to play this to make him play work
c5 this the silly looking rudeness but
he must do it it's no no question than
this one yeah maybe this is good this is
good too white is so good here computer
increase assessed valuation over time
now it's on 0.8
yeah no it'sit's just winning this is
something you cannot do we cannot give
me the edge far you must play this one
but it's never look at this it's
basically that position where white
enjoys an extra pole it's simply this is
just one porn and I always have this
ideas to a breakthrough in the center
why this is clearly better so this means
that probably he he shouldn't play the
smooth allowing this bad porn structure
a six would be a bishop e6 yeah he
defended this very tenacious Lee I was
really thinking all right this will be
an easy win but that it really wasn't
thanks for watching